[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing one of the mysteries
surrounding the first harry potter book
more specifically
we're going to be unpacking why the
first book in the popular franchise
was given two had different names have
you ever noticed while scrolling across
youtube or while perusing the internet
that the first installment of harry
potter is addressed with two
very different names did you ever wonder
why well today we're going to be talking
about harry potter and the philosopher's
stone
versus harry potter and the sorcerer's
stone which came first
which is the correct name why are there
two names
at all let's dive into the history of
the famous book
when jk rowling first wrote harry potter
she had considerable trouble getting it
published
in fact it went completely unrecognized
for five years
that is until barry cunningham from
bloomsbury children's books
gave rolling a chance if it wasn't for
barry cunningham
harry potter might still be languishing
in his cupboard under the stairs
jk rowling has admitted when barry took
the book home
he gave a copy to his daughter and she
couldn't put it down
this is when barry made the decision to
publish rowling's books
what barry certainly didn't know however
was that harry potter would grow
the way that it did the original harry
potter book
titled harry potter and the
philosopher's stone made its debut in
the uk
in 1997. the book was an instant success
and it turned out that scholastic books
had purchased the us rights to the book
before it was released in the uk the us
version came out in 1998
however publishing the book in the us
market also meant that the book
would need to undergo some changes most
notably the name
arthur levine who led scholastic's
us-based harry potter publication
expressed early on his concerns about
the word philosopher
explaining that it might get lost on a
young u.s audience
he felt that philosopher was too
old-fashioned sounding
and instead suggested harry potter and
the school of magic
a title that jk rowling shot down
rowling and scholastic eventually found
common ground
when the title of harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone
was first introduced which used more
commonly used language
while still possessing a clear
connotation to magic
as i'm sure you already know the book
was a massive success in the us market
as well
and whether that's the result of the
altered title or not is unclear
for all of the subsequent books the
titles remain the same in both the us
and uk markets as per rowling's request
however in 2001 when the first harry
potter film came out
outlining the events of the first book
the films were released under different
titles
according to locale most of the world
used philosopher
but in the us and a select few other
markets sorcerer was still used
creating a film for two separate markets
also proved to be quite difficult
as it forced the actors to reshoot
scenes and include the word
sorcerer in place of philosopher rowling
has openly expressed that if she could
go back in time
she would not have changed the name at
all using philosophers across all
markets right from the beginning
americanizing the books didn't just stop
at a title either
as various british isms like mum and
pudding
were changed to things like mom and
dessert
this is something that jk rowling also
put a stop to for subsequent books
what do you guys think was the name
change for the us market pivotal to its
success
or was it totally unnecessary did you
know why these books used different
names
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
you're a wizard harry
you